Welcome to Ear Biscuits, the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we are responding to your
questions and disputes
that you brought to us when we asked you,
"Are you beefing with a friend,
family member, or partner?
Let us settle your
dispute once and for all.
Serious, funny, or bizarre,
we're here to help."
That's us.
Give us a call at
1-88-EARPOD1.
EARPOD1.
So we're gonna do that with our many years
of settling disputes, both with
each other and with others.
We're somewhat experts.
We're peacemakers.
We're peacemakers, but
we're problem solvers.
Problem solvers.
And today,
Engineers.
it's not just about making
peace, it's about being right.
Yeah, right.
We're gonna tell you who definitively
in your dispute is right.
Unless we disagree, which
is gonna get awkward.
But before we get into that,
I have a little update.
I want to give you a little
something I've been sitting on
since I arrived here this morning.
Oh.
As you know, I played in my first ever
celebrity golf tournament yesterday.
I did know that.
Ha-ha, yes I did.
Oh, yeah, so you gotta
play with a celebrity?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, it was the Comedy Gives Back,
2nd Annual Comedy Gives Back
Celebrity Golf Tournament.
And it was funny because I just,
it's something I've always wanted to do.
Like I see-
You want to give back to comedy?
Well, yeah, that.
I see the, like the
celebrity Pro-ams and stuff,
and I like golf and I,
at least in some circles,
am considered a celebrity.
So I was like, just, you
know, little bucket list item.
Let's play in one and see what happens.
So, because I guess in some
senses, I am a comedian,
I was included in this group
of about 25 stand-up comedians.
Oh.
Including
the one and only Bill Burr.
What a standout stand-up comedian.
Yeah, so, like legit stand-up comedians.
Oh, yeah.
Like, respected and
established stand-up comedians
who are so good at stand-up
comedy that they get parts
in The Mandalorian, like,
those kinds of people, right?
Yep.
He was the most well-known one there.
In fact, he may have been the only one who
they auctioned off playing with him,
but they didn't auction off
playing with anybody else.
So, you were assigned to like a foursome?
Yeah, a foursome.
That ended up being a
twosome and then a threesome,
and then the fourth guy didn't
show up 'cause he got COVID.
Long story, but it was, what
they ended up doing for me,
I guess because I was the
oddball, the internet guy,
is as opposed to putting me
with a group of four friends
or like, a group of four
people from a company,
there were the reps for the
brands that were doing things.
So, like the Liquid Death
guy, 'cause Liquid Death was
supplying the water for this.
Just like they supplied for MythiCon.
Big fan.
The guy who was supplying
the shirts for everybody.
And then-
So, you were the brand
liaison comedian.
And then the Porsche guy.
There was a hole where
if you got a hole in one,
you won a Porsche Macan or whatever you-
Oh.
Is it Mecan or Pecan? Mecahn?
That guy, and then there was
another guy who got COVID
and didn't show up.
So anyway, we did not win.
It was fun, yes.
But the thing that I was
actually kind of nervous about
is that they said that
there was going to be
a joke-telling contest at night, at dinner
in front of all these
comedians and all the teams.
And that the comedian from
the team is responsible
for coming up with a joke
and delivering the joke.
Joke-telling contest, even
that as a phrase seems, like,
antiquated and strange.
Well, that's a big part of this.
It was a joke, like a
joke-joke-telling contest.
Not a routine, not a stand-up routine.
Not a story that happened to you.
It was like, you tell a joke joke.
Like, a joke with a
set-up and a punchline.
Which interestingly, in
that comedy community,
you know, especially these
guys who are of this age,
middle-aged or whatever,
you know, stand-up
comedy in the '80s, '90s,
They like a good joke.
there was a lot of jokes.
There's kind of a tradition of jokes,
and so they kind of respect jokes.
Especially, well, and
here's another thing that
you would not be surprised to know.
I would have dropped out
upon finding this out.
Comedians, they've kind of ignored
a lot of things that have
changed in society and they still
just kind of say whatever
the hell they wanna say.
Yeah.
In one sense I sort of respect that,
there's a place where
that's happening in comedy.
That's not your place.
That's not my style, but I respect it.
And so I knew, I was like,
because they were like,
"Anything goes."
So I was like, these are
gonna, it's gonna be so dirty.
People are gonna say inappropriate things,
people are gonna say
politically incorrect things.
None of this is being recorded.
But I was like,
Supposedly.
I have to go, I gotta do
something dirty, right?
And I was also thinking,
I need to do something original,
I'm gonna write my joke.
I'm not gonna go on
Reddit and find a joke.
You can't do that.
Even though that's what a lot of them did.
A lot of them were like, "This
is my uncle's favorite joke."
Or, "This is a joke my dad told me
multiple times growing up."
That's different than
going on Reddit though.
If you're related to the
person who told you the joke.
The guy hosting it was Ben Bailey.
You may remember him as the
guy who hosted Cash Cab.
Oh, yeah.
For 14 seasons.
So, he's a stand-up, so
he's MCing the thing.
Yeah.
Kind of a dry wit.
Other comedians who I'm competing against.
I will say Bill Burr was not
feeling great, so he didn't
stay for the joke contest,
which took some pressure off.
Okay, good.
But Randy-
Did you meet Bill?
I did meet Bill.
I met him before we started playing.
Told him I was representing
YouTube comedy.
What was his reaction to that?
He was like, "Ah, but Bo Burnham, ah,"
Oh, Bo Burnham.
"I mean, that dude's crazy!"
Okay, okay.
So that made me feel good.
He was very nice.
And I met him at the same
time I met Greg Fitzsimmons,
who you would recognize if I
showed you a picture of him.
You know, this guy, he's been like,
you've seen him on The
Tonight Show, whatever,
and he's been around forever.
So Greg was in it,
And then Randy Sklar of
Randy and Jason Sklar,
Sklar Brothers was in the joke.
I went right after
Randy as matter of fact.
So, I'm gonna deliver my joke for you.
Deliver your joke for all of us.
I'm gonna get up there and
do exactly what I did, right?
I grabbed the microphone.
Oh, you gonna stand up?
No, I'm gonna stay seated
because the microphone's here.
And I'm gonna do word
for word what I said.
Sit-down comedy.
And people had done a lot of, like,
classic set-up/punchline jokes,
just to let you know
the world that we're in.
Ben Bailey says, "Rhett
McLaughlin, everybody."
Smattering of applause.
"Disclaimer: I am an internet comedian."
Smattering of laughter.
Okay.
Which means, I don't know
if they're laughing or not.
A little bit more laughter.
"My joke is short.
Why did my ex-wife cross the road?"
"Why?"
"I don't know, I don't keep
up with that fuckin' bitch."
Oh, wow, look at you.
Using the F-bomb and the B-bomb.
That was good.
Jenna and Brian laughed at it.
So, and I'll tell ya...
I'm just over here shocked, Rhett.
I'm gonna, I am not a joke writer, okay?
So, you made that up?
I made that up.
Yeah, but you don't have an ex-wife.
Yeah, yeah.
So, you also made up an ex-wife.
Yeah, right.
Wow.
It was a joke.
The liberties that you're taking.
And Ben Bailey said,
I wouldn't say it killed, but it did well.
It was very respectable,
it was like, I would say,
I didn't make it to the top three.
Why did my ex-wife cross the road?
And then the answer is?
Well, first you said "why?"
Did you have to lean back from
your own mic and say "why?"
No, I was imitating the crowd.
Or did somebody do that?
When you're telling jokes
to a crowd of comedians,
They know.
they say "why?"
Oh, okay.
You know, they give you the other thing.
And they're not gonna jump
on it and guess the answer
like some person at a comedy club.
Like, they're comedians.
They're like, "This guy's telling a joke."
So it's a great crowd for that.
I don't know, I don't keep
up with that fucking bitch.
Yeah, yeah.
"My joke is short", tell
me about that part of it.
Like, why did you feel like
you needed to say that?
Because people had been saying that
if they had a short one.
People would be like, "This
is a long one, settle in."
Some people are like,
"This is a short one."
I feel like the...
I mean, that may have been a mistake.
I feel like if you're open
to constructive feedback.
Oh, I am, but I'm not gonna
get into joke writing,
just so you, don't worry.
You made an excellent choice in having
such a staccato joke, but I
don't think you should have
said "my joke is short"
because that was kind of,
the punch of it was just
how "bam" and it's over.
Because the shortness of
it is part of the surprise.
Well, but once you say, "why did so and so
cross the road?", you
know it's a short joke,
'cause that's a classic
structure of a short joke, so.
Well, that's another reason
you shouldn't have said it.
That's a better reason though.
I don't think that I cut the
joke off, but it was more
that I was just kinda like
feeding off of the things
that people had been saying.
I will say-
What would I have done?
Well, let me tell you right now.
I don't know what I would've done.
I was definitely nervous because
I was just trying to save
face and say something.
Well, you self-deprecated.
Say something, just do
something funny and unexpected.
And I would say that-
You lowered the bar,
you made a joke about it.
Yeah, right.
Then you said something
you shouldn't have said,
then you said a really good joke.
Oh, you like it.
So I see that in the vein of like-
I'm offended.
Like, Norm Macdonald.
I don't know how familiar you are with,
Norm Macdonald when he
was having his show,
his internet show, there
was this joke portion.
And it was, every joke
that Norm Macdonald told
was always a misdirect,
it was like, in that way.
So that's not based on any joke,
but it's based on the structure
of a Norm Macdonald joke,
which is like, I'm not
gonna give you the thing
that you thought I was going to give you,
I'm gonna give you, it's a
joke about the joke, kinda.
How'd you come up with that joke?
It was not easy.
Because I came up with
like four other jokes.
You were thinking about
a knock-knock joke?
Well, no, I was trying
to figure out, like,
how do you write a joke?
Because we don't write jokes.
And so I was like,
Yeah.
Do I, here's what I did.
I would be like, "Okay,
so there was this guy
and he was on a deserted island.
And the only person that survived was him
and another beautiful woman."
And I would just say something like that.
Like, that sounds like
the beginning of a joke.
And I would just see if I could
find a way to a punchline.
I did that, like, on and
off, as I was driving,
as I was doing other things
over the weekend.
Mumbling to yourself.
And I never arrived at anything.
Ooh God, that would've ruined my weekend.
But then I was like,
"You need to go short.
You need to go short."
Yeah.
And then I was like-
And you need to say it's short.
I was like, what about...
Why'd the chicken cross the road?
And I said, yeah, what's a take on that?
I was like, "Why did my
ex-wife cross the road?"
And the first-
"Why?"
And so I'll give you,
this was my dirty one.
And so I was like, "Why did
my ex-wife cross the road?"
"Why?"
"To get to my neighbor's dick."
So that was the first one, right?
Not nearly as good.
I was like, that's not good.
That's not it.
And then when I came up-
Not even close.
Oh yeah, I mean, that's
why I didn't use it.
I'm just saying that
as I'm running through-
I'm agreeing, I'm not slamming
you, I'm agreeing with you.
And I don't know how I came up with it.
But I'm not saying that it's great,
I'm just saying that I was
relieved when I came up with it
because I was like, "This
crowd will appreciate that
and I'll at least walk outta here."
Now, if I had known that they
were just gonna tell jokes
that they knew, I would've
gotten even a better joke.
But I didn't make it to the final three.
Randy did make it to the final three.
I'm trying to remember who else did.
Fitzsimmons made it.
Honestly, I don't really
care at this point.
And then an older comedian, but-
You didn't make it,
that's all I care about.
The guy who won,
'cause what they did
is they did a joke-off
and they kept going.
Oh.
It was an older guy.
You weren't prepared for that.
Oh, no, no.
So if you would've moved
on, it was a new joke.
You didn't tell the same joke,
'cause that doesn't really work.
Yeah, yeah, my next joke
was one that a friend,
Daniel Strange had told me.
Okay.
Which was not, I mean, he was just like,
"What time does Sean Connery
arrive at Wimbledon?"
Oh, this is an accent joke.
Ten-ish.
Which is cute, cute dad joke.
There were people doing that
kind of joke, that people,
I guess people who are clean.
I mean, I kind of think you could've said,
"I don't care, I don't keep
up with that fucking bitch."
Would've worked again.
That's what you would've done.
That's what I would've
done if I had made it.
And then if you would've kept making it,
same punchline every time.
I could have been your joke caddie.
I think you can do it once,
I don't think you can do it a third time.
That would've been funny, dude.
Ten-ish.
They were so dirty.
They were shockingly dirty.
Oh no.
You know, I'm not gonna repeat it.
But there was no doubt in
my mind when a couple of 'em
were delivered, that was
like, "I'm not, I'm not."
And I was like, "Be in
the middle of the pack."
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
"Don't get to the finals because then,
you'll really expose yourself."
And that ain't funny.
Right.
So that's my, you know, it
was a growth experiment.
Growth experience, is
that what I'm looking for?
How did you golf?
You know, okay.
Moments of brilliance,
moments of embarrassment.
Oh, give me a break.
Typical game of golf.
We did not win.
See, my MO is both at the same time.
That's not how I operate.
I know.
I have true moments of brilliance.
Oh, gosh, shut up.
Where you're just like,
"Oh my gosh, that guy."
Shut up.
I have true moments of brilliance.
"That guy, was he a college golfer?"
I'm saying, on the golf course.
Check out Stevie and Neagheen's podcast,
Best Friends Back, Alright!
I want you to do it.
It's never too late to
check out a new podcast
where people are connecting,
where friendships are happening
right before your ears.
Don't do it, if you
don't wanna do it for me,
do it for yourself.
Best Friends Back, Alright!
wherever you get your podcasts.
I think you should do all
things in entertainment,
anything that we're doing at Mythical,
you should make a decision
to watch it for yourself.
Don't do it for us.
We're making this stuff for you.
I went to watch, you know,
I went to the premiere of Slumberland.
You'll see this on Netflix,
it's a movie with Jason Momoa.
But the star of the
movie is Marlow Barkley.
And we, me, Christy, and
Lando, went to the premiere,
we went to that entertainment
event for her and her family
because we are very close friends.
You know, Lando and
Marlow grew up together.
I think Marlow's still 12.
I think her and Lando
are about the same age.
She's not 13 yet.
Marlow is the freakin' star of this movie.
Oh yeah.
And Jason Momoa is like
her supporting character, basically.
So I went to that for her.
But I was absolutely relieved
to find out that I
stayed for me, you know?
You go to things to support your friends
and when it's a work of art, like a movie,
it's like, "Oh crap, what am I gonna,
what am I gonna say
afterward if it sucks?"
It was so good.
So I know it's not my rec this week,
but you just made me think of it.
It paid off to do entertainment
Double rec.
for somebody else.
Check out Slumberland.
If you have kids in that age range,
they will love it.
It feels like the type of story
that you think should have
been done before, but it at
the same time, it's like a,
I don't think it has.
And it's like, it deals
with dreams and it's
wholly original, very-
It's like that Fred Savage movie.
Very fun.
Also a tearjerker.
Where he goes underneath
his house or something?
And I was so proud of Marlow.
She is so good in it.
You remember, we-
Check out Slumberland.
We wanted her to be,
when she was just getting
started with her acting,
we wanted her to be the
little girl in the episode
of Buddy System where
the little girl comes to
That's right.
the door selling candy.
And then it goes into this,
like, old frontier story.
There was a conflict of her.
That's right.
She was committed to
something else or whatever,
so we couldn't do it.
We could have derailed her
whole acting career if she
had done that Buddy System thing.
Yeah, that's true.
She probably made
the right choice.
Let's get into these voicemails.
I mean, it's about time
to settle some disputes.
I'm just gonna start
right here at the top.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
I'm feuding with my mom because
she has eaten half of my freezer.
All 20 breakfast sandwiches
I just bought from Costco.
Don't know what to do.
Please help.
Oh dang, I'm sorry.
I feel like I need more details.
Like, was this in one sitting?
I know, that's a lot of
breakfast sandwiches.
Was this over the course of
72 hours?
If she was that hungry,
let her have it.
Because if you've got a
20-sandwich package from Costco,
I would think that most people
are anticipating that lasting
at least a month.
You know, unless you're, I mean,
even if you're the kind
of person who's eating it
every single morning, you're making it
20 days.
That's three weeks, yeah.
We have breakfast
sandwiches in our freezer.
I do not eat them because I
don't think they can actually be
good for you.
And I eat a smoothie every morning.
Who eats the breakfast sandwiches?
My kids eat 'em.
Christy doesn't eat 'em either.
So we haven't experienced this issue.
You mean like a Jimmy Dean?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what Shepherd's into.
I have a reputation of
being one to just unapologetically
take people's stuff
after taking Tim's salsa from the fridge
for that GMM episode.
Yeah, that wasn't a good look for me.
And every time I see Tim now
I still feel bad about it,
but it sounds like her mom is
unapologetic or unconversant
about it, because she's thinking
she's the one that needs to
do something about it.
I think, isn't it as simple as a question?
"Mom, do you know that these,"
"Mom, what do you," I don't
know, I'm trying to think of
like a nonaccusatory question.
"You like those breakfast
sandwiches I bought for myself,
don't you, Mom?"
"What do you think of those?"
"In my mind, those are my
breakfast sandwiches, Mom."
Well, I don't-
"Whose are they in your mind?"
I don't think that that's necessarily,
I don't think that she is
saying that her mom can't eat
any of her breakfast sandwiches.
She's saying that her mom ate all
of her breakfast sandwiches.
Yeah.
I don't know if she was on vacation.
I don't know if her mom
had a breakfast party.
I don't know the context,
but I'm assuming-
Mom should be replacing
these breakfast sandwiches.
that she just ate way
too many in too short
of a period of a time.
And she obviously had
bought them not primarily,
or not exclusively, but
primarily for herself, right?
I mean, I'm assuming that
there's some sort of shared budget.
You're sharing a house, you know,
it's not like, this isn't
necessarily a roommate situation
where there's separate bank accounts.
This is my stuff, I have my
name on it, I budgeted for this.
Mom does have some sort of
a trump card to play here,
I believe, probably, from
a budget perspective.
She could be cashing in on a parent tax.
If I knew that, if I knew
that earlier in life,
she wasn't the kind of mom who
would reach over and eat some
of her kids' food in the way that
I have done throughout my
life, then maybe she's just
making up for it all in like a week.
One crazy binge.
Like I said, I'm not one to
talk here, but at my house,
Lando will Post-it Note
stuff in the fridge.
And I know Tim did that with the salsa.
It was extenuating circumstances.
Do I need to apologize again, Tim?
I'm sorry.
Well hold on, but do you
do this to Lando, do you eat Lando's?
Mm... no.
Well give me an example of something that
Lando would Post-it Note.
Some special mochis in the freezer.
Some special chocolate
milks in the fridge.
Leftovers.
That's where I get him.
Because he'll label the leftover,
but I know he's not
gonna go back and eat it.
And so I feel like I'm
doing a service to just
glean the fridge from stuff
that is gonna be thrown away
if it's not eaten today.
Well at least you can get
him to label it, like,
I can't get my kids, my kids
won't eat leftovers, man.
I eat every, I eat all the leftovers.
Like that's the first place I go at night
is what's left over.
Oh really?
Yeah, it just feels...
I think that she should, I
think you gotta try labeling.
That's my, that's my
thing, just start there.
Yes, it's a little passive aggressive.
Rebuy the sandwiches yourself.
Then you're in a position
of power, and you label it.
Or have a conversation with your mom
if you're still on speaking terms.
Yeah, I think this is just
a, there's a easy solve here,
which is a conversation and saying,
"Hey, if you really like
these breakfast sandwiches,
which apparently you do and I do as well,
maybe we get the 40-pack next time."
Right.
You know?
There's a compromise on the horizon.
Yeah.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
My name is Robert, I'm
calling from BC in Canada.
My wife and I have a constant argument
about what is "ground"
and what is "floor".
I like to call the outside
where anything is paved
or has cement on it, anything
like that, the ground,
or the floor, she says
that it's still the ground.
My argument is that it is called
the floor because anything
that is not dirt can't
be considered the ground
because it is made by people.
So I think it's called the
floor, she thinks it's called
the ground because it's outside.
So that's our argument
that we constantly have.
And it has created some
really funny moments in our
marriage, and I'd like you
guys to settle it for us.
All right.
Have a good day, bye.
He said he'd like for
us to settle it for him.
It seems pretty simple.
Robert, you're wrong.
The floor is inside,
the ground is outside.
It's not about being manmade
or not unless it's something
that's like... oh, shoot.
I have an exception.
Am I wrong?
I have an exception that I think.
Now I'm thinking there's
exceptions to that,
but I think that's the starting point.
I also think that Robert is
somewhat wrong.
Maybe you're right
in some instances.
But it's not, the distinction
is not inside and outside.
If it's inside it is floor.
And if it's dirt outside, it is ground.
Like, those extremes.
Nope, and you are not letting
me get my thought out.
That's what I think.
And then somewhere in the
middle we can hash it out.
How do you disagree with that?
It has nothing to do
with being inside and
outside, it has to do with
whether or not there
is a canopy or a roof.
That's why we call it the forest floor.
We don't call it the forest
ground, and that is because
there is a canopy of trees and
like, "on the forest floor."
But you don't say on
the floor of the meadow
or the floor of the valley
because that's open.
So it has to do not with being
outside, but with being open.
So a patio does not have a floor
unless it is a screened-in porch.
Now we're in a situation where you can say
"that's the floor of the porch."
It's all about whether or not
there is something over the
top of you, and it doesn't
have to be human-made.
It's just, is there a clear
shot to the sky, and if so,
whatever is underneath you
is not floor but ground.
Well, that's nice Rhett.
That is a nice analysis.
But, patio is neither floor
nor ground, it is patio.
I agree with that.
So if there's no canopy over
your patio and it's still
like a cement, just like a cement slab,
you can't call it ground because it's...
Now I'm about to agree with
him, because it's manmade.
But you can't call it floor
because to your point,
there's no canopy.
But if you were on a
patio that was covered.
A floor has to have a canopy.
I agree with that.
Yeah.
But a forest floor is also ground.
There's common ground with
the forest in that it is both.
And a patio is neither,
because it's just a patio.
It's a patio, like you look
down, it's like, what is that?
Is that the patio floor?
Is that the patio ground?
Is it the patio floor?
Well, but by nature.
I'm all over the place.
By nature, a patio does not have a canopy.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
A porch.
The difference between a porch and a patio
Is the canopy.
is the canopy.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
And if you're talking about
the retractable canopy,
I have one of those.
that doesn't count,
that doesn't make it a
floor, it's not like, oh,
it's a floor when it's out and it's not.
No, no, no.
I'm talking about, there's
gotta be some supports.
This thing's gotta be able
to stand up in the wind
because you need to be
able to call it a ceiling.
So if I'm on a porch
somewhere and I look up,
like I was talking to your dad at MythiCon
about the ceilings of porches
Yeah.
that are painted blue.
And my understanding based on
all these conversations that I
had with people in the south,
was that they're painted blue
because of bugs, which I never believed,
but that was what people told me, like,
"flies don't like the light blue."
And your dad was like,
"it's like the sky."
Yeah.
It's like looking like the sky.
And he says they also do mint green,
like mint green or baby blue,
those are the two colors.
But that's the ceiling of the porch,
is what you would call that.
If I was talking to a
painter, he would say,
"What color do you want me to paint
the ceiling of the porch?"
Wouldn't he?
Or would he say, "Do you want me to paint
the underside of the awning?"
Eh, I think he would say ceiling.
The porch ceiling.
And then what color do you
want me to paint the floor
of the porch?
What color do you want
me to stain the patio
floor, the porch floor?
Patio is different.
I'm just trying it out.
Patio, I think of as like just a square
either concrete or wood
or brick or something
that you might have an umbrella on.
Now, my backyard is pavers.
Like, individual stones
It's a pool deck.
that are laid.
You could call it a deck
because there is a pool there,
but there's parts of it,
even the part with the retractable awning.
Not a floor.
I'm trying to think of
what I've called that.
Like, "I need to blow off the back."
That's what I just say,
I call it the back.
The back.
I don't call it, it's not
ground and it's not floor.
It's pavers.
Yeah, but what do you call that area?
The back.
You might call that a patio.
I'm glad we could settle this.
So I think that we found
a third alternative here.
I don't know if it was
illuminating at all, but I,
I think that Robert's
distinction is wrong.
If there's a permanent canopy,
then underneath it is a floor.
And if it's naturally occurring
un-canopied surface
outdoors, that's ground.
So at least take those
things off the table.
And if you've got an old-school house,
there's plenty of houses
that have dirt floors,
and that is also the ground.
But it also happens to
be the floor of the home.
But it's a dirt floor.
Yep.
So floor and ground can be the same thing
if your floor is ground.
There you go.
Please explain to my husband that watching
your own kid
is not babysitting.
Thank you.
Ouch.
Oh, this is heated.
I love the fact that you could
hear children just making a
racket in the background of the voicemail.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, this is the world from
which this lovely woman is
exasperatedly leaving us a voicemail.
Yeah.
You ever been guilty of this?
I'm sure.
I mean, I'm sure.
Using the term "babysit" to
take care of your own kids?
I don't know if I've ever done that.
Well, even if you don't use the term,
there's definitely
playing this card of like,
"Well, I watched them."
I don't go so far as to say
"I'm babysitting the kids"
like it's a paid occupation.
But if you watched them,
you're implying there's other
times you didn't watch them.
"I'm gonna watch the kids
so you can do something."
As opposed to the other times
when you don't watch them.
Which is usually.
And our kids are of an age that, you know,
they don't need to be watched anymore.
But like, when our kids were watching age,
I would always use it
as, like, some sort of
a merit badge that never worked.
And and I agree, it wasn't
valid, you know, because,
I mean, Christy and Jessie,
they were homeschool
teachers as well as moms.
Like, so much of their time
was tending to these children.
Good gosh.
By their own choice.
Yeah, yeah, it wasn't-
Just to be clear.
I kept telling Jessie year after year,
"You wanna stop doing that?"
Stop watching these kids.
You need to stop being the babysitter.
But yeah, it's like when you step in,
it would be, like, something exceptional.
Yeah, that's a card
you can't play, my man.
Yeah, your wife's right.
Just stop using that term
when you watch the kids.
You cannot do that.
We have a serious category.
You want to get into like a serious one?
And then come back to a less serious one?
Yeah, 'cause we might need
a little relief, you know?
Okay.
Let's start here.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
Me and my girlfriend recently have been
butting heads a little bit.
She's been working a lot, and
I'm very proud of all the work
that she's been doing and all
the money she's been saving.
She's trying to move out right now.
So I understand why she's
been in her grindset,
in her, you know, girlboss
money moves era, but
sometimes I just want her to
acknowledge the fact that I am
also still here and that I am,
you know, a part of her
life and someone that
would like to spend time with her.
I have a difficult dilemma
on my hands though,
because it's an interesting dichotomy,
this feeling of being so proud
of her for working so hard,
but at the same time
wishing that she would
at least admit a little
bit that there is a strain
on our relationship because
of how much she works.
I'm not exactly sure what
to do and I would love
your guys' feedback.
Help me out, help out this
struggling Mythical Beast.
Anyway, appreciate you guys.
I love all you do, keep on keepin' on.
I really do appreciate all
your content and all your
happiness that you give to the world.
Have a good one.
Okay.
Well, as that question
was being asked, Jenna.
Couldn't stay in her seat.
I mean, she was, you know,
so I kind of feel like we should
let the woman in the room.
Jenna, we'd love for you
to kick this one off.
To give us an initial
reaction to this question.
It sounds like he
has not had this conversation
with his partner.
Yeah.
And that is a conversation
that he needs to have
with her, and his tone was a little...
I don't think he meant anything by it.
I think his tone came across a little
iffy, but it's clear,
it's a hard thing to do because,
what do you say when in that situation?
I don't know, it's just one
of those where it's like,
if the roles were reversed,
it would be a conversation you
wanna have with your partner.
Like, if the man was working too much
and the woman or whichever,
however, the partnership is.
Either way, he's feeling, he
sounds real sad, and I think,
he just gotta have,
set, plan a date night.
Just the two of them, get
out of their normal stuff,
and have a conversation.
And another thing I think
that you all can advise on, is
one thing about your relationships
I think is really cool
that you do is you have a
set day where you spend time
with your wives.
Like, you have planned time with them.
That is part of your schedule.
And it seems like with his
girlfriend's new schedule getting
so crazy and how amazing
that is for her that
maybe they need to discuss
scheduled quality time.
Well,
Yeah.
it's interesting, because
I feel like in some senses,
there's, I can relate to
this right now, right?
You know, over the past
couple years Jessie has
really started doing, she
really kind of started leaning
into her interior design stuff.
And then, really in the past,
like, two years especially,
and then this year, you
know, she's taken on a number
of clients, she just got
through a really big project.
And the way that her time was structured,
which was very unusual for me, was
getting home and she's working.
She's working when I get home.
And she's working, like,
at least when it got to
crunch time, we're not
watching TV together.
Now, when you've been married
to somebody for 21 years,
in one sense it's like, oh,
well Jessie's busy right now.
I'm gonna go watch something
that she would never
watch with me.
You know what I'm saying?
It's an opportunity?
Yeah, it's like, because I am, we've,
I've spent a lot of time with
her and I'm gonna continue to
spend a lot of time with her
and this is sort of
extenuating circumstances.
Yeah, that is a good corollary point,
that the cumulative time that you spend.
But I don't think that is applicable
to this particular situation.
I'm just assuming because
it sounds like, you know,
kind of still building the
relationship in a lot of ways.
Not that I'm not building
the relationship anymore,
but you know what I mean.
But there's also this
thing where it's like,
in the context of my
relationship with Jessie is that
so much of what her life has been about
and what her activities have
revolved around and where she
lives, revolves around
is me and my work, right?
Yeah.
Which tends to be a more
traditional, you know,
given the history of the
world and the patriarchy,
like, that tends to be the situation.
It's like, well the man's
gonna do this and I've gotta
support him in doing this.
And that was our story for,
you know, a really long time.
Now, as the kids have gotten
older and Jessie has a lot of
aspirations and dreams and
things that she wants to do,
quote unquote her, I don't
know, I'm gonna choose to say
that he was doing this in a loving way.
Her "girlboss money making moves".
Right.
I will say... those terms are kind of not-
That seemed like it could be, yeah, right.
used anymore by women.
Yeah, right.
So, there's other things.
But it's been an interesting
thing for me to be someone
who, I feel like I've gotten...
She's done so much for me,
she's done so much for me,
which I don't know the
history of their relationship,
but for me there's this like,
oh, I can go and be a part
of this thing that's all about Jessie, and
I kinda fade into the background
and kinda can support her.
But as it relates to our time
together, even our date night
has gotten canceled for the past six weeks
because she's been so busy.
But that project is over, we'll
do the date night this week.
We're kind of getting back,
as long as we kinda return
to the normal of actually
spending quality time
with each other.
And I think that what Jenna
was saying at the beginning
about, you know, these are
the bread and butter
conversations of a relationship.
It's like, when it comes
to stuff like this,
this is where the magic happens, honestly.
If you can really connect
about not being able to connect.
I think there's a way in, is not,
it's not corrective, like, don't
take a corrective approach.
Maybe think about having more of a
still supportive and
celebratory, and it's like,
I'm celebrating what you're doing,
I'm supporting what you're doing,
but it's creating a challenge
that kind of frames it.
But then your motive,
where you're coming from,
is love and wanting to connect
and missing a level of intimacy.
And I think that, you
know, if you approach it
from that angle, as
long as that's truthful,
that's gonna go a long way, right?
You know?
Yeah.
To say, "Hey, let's put,
can we put something on the calendar?
Can we put a plan in place where
I don't feel threatened by
what you're going after,
but I can be your
biggest fan and champion,
but still have my needs met
by you in our relationship?"
'Cause it is a reality that
if the time that you would
otherwise spend together
is spent apart because of work,
you have to manage that
reality in your relationship.
Some people, two busy
professionals who work late
and are like, "We see each
other on the weekends."
And that's
An agreement.
We've agreed to that,
we've communicated that,
we have, our expectations are in line.
Yeah.
It's all about,
obviously the expectations
are not aligned right now.
And you have to figure
out, can they be aligned?
And if they can't, then
that's a different conversation, you know?
Yeah, leave us another
voicemail if that doesn't work.
We'll put Jenna back on it, yes!
Here's another one.
Let's stay serious.
Hey guys, this is Mike from Michigan.
So I've been in a beef with my
sister for, oh, 14 years now.
And well, let's just say
she's not exactly all the
way there in the head.
And she got in a fist fight
with my dad of all people
who was extremely old at the
time and I was never able
to forgive her for it, and
I don't know how to forgive her for it.
And now my niece and nephew
want to get involved with me,
her kids, and my niece is my
goddaughter, and I don't know
how to bring them back into my life
without bringing her into my life.
I know it's horrible to take your sister
out of your life and your
way, but it's just kind of
something I don't want to be
involved in my life anymore,
but I really want my niece and
nephew involved in my life,
if that makes any sense.
Sorry, a little nervous.
But if you guys can maybe
approach this in a way for me
where I can get them back
into my life and somehow
make it work with my sister too.
I don't know if that's
possible, but thanks, guys.
Wow.
Mike, thanks for sharing your story.
Our hearts go out to you.
I know when you said 14 years,
our hearts just kind of dropped, you know?
That's sad.
It seems like it's sad for
everybody involved, and it's
kind of intimidating to speak
into your situation knowing
only what you just
shared in the voicemail.
Again, I thank you for sharing it,
but I just wanna acknowledge that, like,
we're definitely out of our depth here.
So I think the first thing I
wanna do is just say, you know,
from a heart level, just that
like, we feel for you and,
you know, I've had estranged
long-term relationships and
it doesn't feel good
because it's not, you know,
it's not the natural order of things.
You see so many, you know,
you imagine those relationships
where everything's
working out and you see people
having relationships with,
in this case, their siblings
and it's what you don't have.
And I just know how
difficult that could be.
I also know that there's
situations, and again,
we don't know enough
about your situation to
be prescriptive, but in general there's,
there is a reality where
it's the right decision,
it's the best decision to
put boundaries in place
and sometimes, and that's
along a whole spectrum.
Sometimes that means that
there isn't any contact and
that may be, that's the
best choice for some people
in some situations, you know?
And there's this whole
range and when you've got
nieces and nephews involved,
that, a lot of times, I
have to think makes it hurt
that much more.
Yeah, I think, I mean, I
completely agree that we're not,
you know, we can't give
you specific advice.
But there are principles that are true
that are true in your situation as well.
Like Link said to me, I think,
it's almost overused at this
point, the term "boundaries".
It's used as much as people
labeling other people
"narcissists", it's like,
it's the thing that we all do
on social media, but there's
a lot of truth in it.
And I think that...
it's okay to set a boundary
that is painful to implement
because sometimes the pain
that you and someone else would
experience if that boundary
did not exist is even greater.
But both are painful.
Like, the boundary being in
place and the boundary not being
in place are both painful experiences.
So sometimes there's not a great
solution, and I don't know,
I mean I think that
conceivably, depending on your
circumstances and what the proximity is,
are you in the same town?
How old are the niece and nephew?
Is this the kind of thing
that if there was any kind of
contact it would lead to...
Like what would the problems,
what would the nature of the problems,
you kinda have to think
about it like that, think,
"What are the boundaries
that I could set?"
I don't know, maybe there is
a boundary that you can set
where it's like, my contact
with my sister is gonna be
in relation to logistical
things regarding my time
with her kids.
I'm not saying that's what
you should do, but I'm-
Right, but there may be a
creative solution somewhere
in the middle, and when-
It's like gerrymandering a new district,
you have to navigate your
specific situation but draw the
boundary and communicate the boundary.
So it's like, when I don't
talk to you about this,
it's because I'm setting this boundary.
If you're not okay with that, then
I'm not gonna have the
boundary here at all, or the
boundary's gonna be extended
and I'm gonna have to
push everybody out.
And sometimes they can move,
so it's not like you're
making one decision and then that's it.
So I guess the first
thing we're saying is,
you don't have to make an
all or nothing decision.
There's like this whole
spectrum along the way that
you could make these,
even if it's a convoluted
type of gerrymandered boundary.
But then, you know, two days
later or two months later,
you might discover that
that needs to move.
It needs to tighten up,
or it could loosen up.
You know, there's...
If forgiveness is at play, that, you know,
it's always something worth considering.
But it's, you know.
I think we just have to leave it at that.
'Cause it also depends on your
personal tolerance, right?
Right.
There are some people who
might be in a situation where
any contact with a person would
be too triggering for them
where they just can't do it.
And there might be
situations where it's like,
this person is difficult,
annoying, whatever,
an inconvenience, but I'm not
unsafe and I'm not gonna be,
you know, my mental health
won't be compromised.
Only you know that in a given situation.
What your personal level of tolerance is.
There are people that you can
choose to have in your life
so long as you know the
reality of what it means.
Right.
And you admit that reality to yourself.
Like finding a trusted
resource, which could be
a therapist, I think is
a great avenue to pursue
for something like this.
A sounding board that you may
have to pay for, you know?
If you don't have someone in your life.
Jenna?
Yeah, I will say I do
have something comparable
to that in my history with certain family.
My speaking to, especially,
that you mentioned,
"she's not right in the
head", so perhaps there's some
mental health issues going on.
My father, the last five,
seven years of his life dipped
heavily into alcoholism and it
ultimately caused him to die
from chronic alcoholism.
And it was one of those
situations where similar to
mental health issues, it's a
hard place to be in because
you know that person isn't
their mental health issue.
Like, that isn't who they
are in their entirety.
You see glimmers of who they
could be and who they were
before, who they are when
they're on the right medication,
when they're not, you know,
drinking, kind of scenarios.
And there were boundaries
that we had to set up and some
of my family members had
much stronger boundaries
than I necessarily did.
But I also had a couple
boundaries as well.
And it was, I mean, it's gut-wrenching
when those boundaries are broken,
but they're the boundaries
that you have to set
to protect everyone else.
And some things that we would do was,
Dad could come to public
events and support us,
but he couldn't be drinking,
and if he had been drinking
we would steal his car
keys, like a whole scenario.
So like, if you wanna test the
waters of being able to see
your nieces and nephews, 'cause
that's must be devastating
that you're not able to
be a part of their lives
and a positive role model to them as well,
I would suggest something
a bit more public,
like if they have, you know,
if they have extracurriculars.
That way you don't have to
sit next to your sister,
but you could still be
there supporting your
niece and nephew, just like
really low touch things,
and forgiveness changes.
14 years is a very long
time to carry that.
And I feel for that, and I
have known people who have
been in really awful abusive
situations with parents or
with other siblings that
as they have all aged,
the boundaries have opened up again.
The lines of communication have
opened up again very slowly.
But I highly recommend,
yeah, certainly speaking
to a healthcare professional,
like a therapist
on the best path forward.
But yeah, I 100% feel this situation
and there's no easy way to do it.
Yeah, exactly.
Every path forward is difficult.
Thanks Jenna, for sharing that.
Yeah.
Well, we went serious.
All right, so we talked about going back.
Let's mix it up a little bit.
All right, so now we're
gonna take a hard left turn.
Hi Rhett and Link, longtime
fan of Ear Biscuits
and Good Mythical Morning.
So I have a dispute that
my partner and I have had.
When you are sitting down
on the commode and you go
to clean up the area, do you
do it from the front or back?
Let me know.
Love you guys.
Well this is, this is easy.
You're supposed to go front to back.
Well that's not, that
wasn't what was asked.
It was, do you go down
Oh.
from the front or do you go
around the from the back?
Oh.
Wipe direction is, obviously
that's front to back.
Everybody knows that,
especially if you have a vagina,
you don't wanna be wiping
the fecal matter towards it.
Come on now.
Just to be very specific.
You can get, you know,
if you got a ballsack,
you can get some shit on your ballsack,
it's not the end of the world,
but I don't recommend it.
This is so great.
But, and again, I do think
that whether or not you-
Just don't leave it there for 14 years.
To tie it into the last.
I think whether or not you
have a penis is somewhat,
you know, relevant.
Irrelevant.
Well no, I'm saying that like,
It's too far.
It's too far from the action.
I mean for me,
to try to go through
the space that is being
currently filled with manhood.
I didn't even hear the question that way.
I couldn't even hear the question.
Did you hear the question that way?
That it was like, you go in
from the front of your... no.
It's just, don't do that.
Yeah, but some people
might think, apparently,
someone in this situation, we
don't know if it's the caller
or the partner.
Because you have to go
back to front when wiping,
if you're reaching through the front.
You're pushing.
you're bulldozing.
You're bulldozing.
Which is very difficult to do.
That's not gonna work.
Yeah, yeah, that's not
really a wipe, that's a push.
You don't wanna do that.
Yeah, so I think you go around the back.
Now, the real question is,
do you stand up or not?
Uh... no?
If you stand up, the cheeks come together.
What are you talking about?
Oh, not if you stand up and bend over.
Well then, yeah, but if you
stand up and then bend over,
the cheeks come together.
The bidet changes everything.
Just get a freakin' bidet, y'all.
Bidet changes everything.
Oh my gosh.
It's bi-day and night, the difference.
But if I do not have access to a bidet,
my final wipe is a standing wipe.
So you can exit that much quicker?
I just feel like, I'm like, one more time
just to make absolute sure.
Why would you stand up for the last wipe?
I don't know, it feels
like it's ceremonial.
And you're bent over?
Ritualistic.
You're like hinging?
Well yeah, you got, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, no one's watching.
You know, I'm not, it's
not a show for anybody.
I'll take some video if you want.
Nope, I don't want, thanks for asking.
But, okay.
Hey Rhett and Link, it's
Kaylin from New Jersey.
I'm beefin' with my mom because
she thinks I'm a monster
for not having the toothpaste
perfectly squeezed down
to the bottom every time.
I kinda think you don't need
to do that until you're at the
very end trying to get
every little bit of it out.
But I don't know, am I a monster?
You know, I appreciate the
question, and the love, Kaylin.
You are not a monster.
And I think this represents
an area of growth for me.
And I would like to pat
myself on the back, you know?
I used to think you had to
squeeze from the bottom.
I was in the mom's camp,
but then I realized,
you know what, who gives a crap?
I mean, just squeeze it
from wherever you want.
But do you have to deal?
'Cause I would've thought
that Christy did it the
quote unquote "correct" way as well?
Well, Christy and I do
not share toothpaste.
Do you use a different brand?
Yes.
Okay, is that why?
But even if we didn't,
we each have our own drawer
with all of our stuff in it
and nothing's shared.
So that's a key here, is
like, have your own toothpaste
and do whatever you want with it.
Yeah, I have my own as well.
I used to think that the right
way to do it is to squeeze
from the bottom because at some
point that is the right way.
But I agree with you, Kaylin.
You can wait to the last, 'til
you need to do it and then
you just take it and you grab
the end of it and you put it
on the edge of the counter
and you 90 degree that thing
over the counter and use it
to get all of the toothpaste
to the end and get the
last little bits out.
But you don't have to do it every time.
The reason why it's a personal
growth from me is because
I can look at that quote
unquote "imperfect"
tube of toothpaste that's
just been, like, squeezed
like a monster in the middle
and say, you know what?
I can live with this unsettling reality.
It's totally fine, it's totally fine.
It's exposure therapy.
Then later, I'll squeeze
it all down there.
I'll make sure it's all out.
So Kaylin, your mom is the monster
and I used to be that monster.
Well,
Get your own toothpaste.
have you noticed that
toothpaste tube technology
has largely, for many brands,
made this argument irrelevant?
Have you noticed this trend?
That they... what?
Every single toothpaste
that I've bought in the past
five years, at least the
brands that I frequent.
You know, I'm not talking,
it's not 1985 toothpaste
where it's just like-
It's not like a foil container?
It's a toothpaste tube that
every time you squeeze it,
it returns to its original shape.
Every single time.
Like, the Quip toothpaste
tube is like that.
Yeah, and then I have
this, I started using the,
after they told me
something about my enamel,
I started using the
Pronamel, like, enamel one,
it does the same thing,
and then I just got one,
'cause the last time I
went to the toothpaste,
to the toothpaste person, to
the dentist, they were like,
you know, "We're gonna
have to do a cleaning every
four months because you
get buildup so fast."
And so now I switched to
one that attacks buildup.
And it's the same thing.
And it's just like, you just
take it, grasp it, squeeze it,
and it takes care of itself.
I think the toothpaste
people are trying to make
this dispute irrelevant.
They're trying to take this
out of the conversation.
But it necessitates doing
what I say which is,
at a certain point you
can't tell how empty it is.
But you gotta do that.
You gotta do the pumps
technique, the fold and squeeze.
That's not, well, no, I don't
do the fold and squeeze.
I don't do the roll-up.
I do the hang it over
the edge of the counter.
It's actually a fun little thing to do.
I'll send you a video if you want.
Okay.
I'll be naked.
I think the fold and squeeze
I'll also be wiping.
accomplishes the same thing,
at least in the tubes
that I've currently got.
It does, it does.
So I think that the world
is becoming a better place
through technology.
It's a lot more time.
It's a lot more time to
do the fold and squeeze
and it's not worth it.
You're taking it out and
putting in on the counter?
That seems like a, I'm literally-
No, it's an easy motion.
Whoosh, squeeze.
I'm pickin' up, foldin'
it and squeezin' it.
Boom, it's done.
And then when it gets down
to like the last ounce,
if I can get two more
brushes outta this.
When you fold it and squeeze
though, some of it is being
sent the wrong direction.
Those last two brushes,
I'm not even interested
in that toothpaste.
Call me wasteful all you want to.
I'm not working hard
for brushing my teeth.
I'm not working that hard
for the last two days.
I do, it's a personal victory.
If you need a personal
victory in your life,
get the last of the toothpaste out.
Why don't you get some
scissors and cut it open?
You ever thought of that?
I've done that.
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
It's a personal victory.
If the scissors are already there.
Like, I'm not gonna go find scissors.
You've cut into a toothpaste tube?
Yeah.
Now that's a different
type of person right there.
I mean, different from me.
Personal victories.
Okay.
I feel like the personal
victory for us today is that
we covered a lot of ground,
we covered a lot of emotions,
and now we just need
another recommendation
to go with my Slumberland.
I'm going to recommend a
creator, a content creator,
whose TikTok and YouTube
channel I quite enjoy.
Okay.
His name is Forrest Valkai,
I think I'm saying the last name.
Forrest with two Rs.
You are saying the name, but
are you saying it correctly?
I think I'm saying it correctly.
Spell it all.
Forrest with two Rs and
then V-A-L-K-A-I, Valkai.
And he talks on YouTube and TikTok.
On TikTok he is @renegadescienceteacher.
But he talks a lot about
things that I'm interested in,
about, you know, fossils and evolution.
He just started a new
series where he's going
into real depth about evolution.
You know, he's a good
guy, he's a nice guy.
He's not
He's a good boy.
trying to make fun of people
or say that people are dumb
or whatever, that's not his
point, his point is just
like, "This is what we know
about this stuff, and
it's pretty awesome."
Forrest Valkai.
All right, we'll speak at you next week.
As always, use #EarBiscuits
to continue the conversation
in written form.
And if you wanna respond to
anything we said today or in any
episode or to any of the prompts
that we put out on
Twitter, you can call us at
1-888-EARPOD1.
1!
Did I lose you?
Yeah, you did.
I'm back though.
Bye.
Hi, I'm currently beefing
with my best friend.
I don't know if we're technically
ex-best friends right now,
but she accepted a job offer
that was sent out to me.
We were both offered the
job and we talked about it.
She said she did not want
the job, that it was not her
career field, it's not what
she wanted to do in the future.
And I really, really wanted the job.
And then they extended
the offer to both of us
and she took it.
And when she took it, they
decided to no longer give it
to me and needless to say,
I didn't take it well.
I think I overreacted
a little bit, but yeah,
I think I'm past it now, I
have a new job and everything's
fine, but I still have a little
bit of resentment with it.
Thank you guys, love you.
[Theresa Ann] Hey, Rhett
and Link, Theresa Ann here.
I'm calling in reference to
the fact that I am beefin'
with my sister once again.
Just because she has a
child, does she get the right
to be the sole host of every holiday?
Thanks, love you guys.
Keep up the great work.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
This is Lydie from Houston, Texas.
Just wanted to call in
and try to get some advice
for a beef I currently
have with my husband.
I am wanting to put our
Christmas tree up already.
I'm very excited about the holiday season.
I love how the Christmas
tree just lights up the room
and all the cheer and joy
it brings to the house.
But of course, he does
not want me to put it up
until after Thanksgiving.
But man, I really wanna
put that Christmas tree up.
Thank you so much, love y'all.
Bye.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.